each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so in this session Tom and I are going
to talk a little bit about what we do in
the imperialist auctioneering group and
microscope research and then Peter realm
box going to tell us some about what
he's been up to lately so originally
notching out coupon was going to give
the talk he couldn't make it but this
really is the three people to make a
grouper myself and Tom and nochi and
then Brendan Murphy is kind of an
associate at Microsoft Research
Cambridge but does a lot of similar
stuff we do a lot of work with him those
are our pictures over on your right so
in our group we have kind of two main
goals one is to gain insight
understanding from product processes
from people from customers and we do
this generally well if you went to the
keynote this morning Wolfram talked a
lot about what we do with grab a
quantitative and qualitative data we be
able to do empirical studies try to
understand how things work and then once
once we're able to test the hypothesis
or understand how a certain process
works and what its effects are we try to
help soft remote teams by providing
tools when we can evidence and database
tools and then also making
recommendation providing best practices
and suggestions for them to improve that
process and one of the kind of unique
things about working at Microsoft
Research and some of these may apply to
to some of you especially if you come
from industrial backgrounds is that
because we're Microsoft and Microsoft is
in the process of producing software we
have easy access to industrial data so
we have some questions we want to answer
we can go to product groups and talk to
them and gather their data and and by
having us access to the data and the
people I allows us some insight that
sometimes is more difficult to do in a
university setting and then likewise if
we've come up with some tool to help
developers or some practice to put in
into place we have a number of product
coops are interested in getting that
feedback from us and they can
immediately put it to you so if you come
with a tool we can immediately tell if
that tool is actually useful or not
because people will begin using it and
then of course we have we've got
a number of people in other areas like
machine learning computer vision other
things that we can collaborate with
within Microsoft Research and then we
have the opportunity to collaborate with
people outside of microsoft research as
well and some of the people who
collaborated even in this room to give
you an idea of some of the people that
we've collaborated with here's a map
with locations of people that we've
collaborated with the black push pins
are our labs and an orange locations of
collaborators and then the list over
there on the side so like Harold came
and visit us for twice for a couple
months in the summer and we're always
looking for good interns to work with
we're definitely open to collaboration
with both University and industrial
types so I to give you a feel for what
we do I wanted to present some kind of a
smattering of some other results and
tools that we've come up with in three
main areas is what we've been looking up
over the past few years I'm going to
talk about socio-technical congruence
which is kind of interplay between the
software itself the entities that we
produce and the developers and how how
the human side of software engineering
comes into play with with a technical
side and then Tom's took going to talk
about some work looking at bug reporting
and triage and also analytics and data
driven software engineering so both my
my PhD dissertation and whatever doing
at Microsoft is really focused on the
people and big orange stroustrup is one
of considered the father of the C++
programming language and he said design
and programming or human activities
forget that and all is lost and so in
our quest to kind of understand software
development in the large we've been
looking at people and that's led to some
interesting insights so I'm going to
present three studies the first study is
where we've decided to look at
distributed development and what if any
effects it has on quality and for each
of the slides we have a list of who was
who took part in the study so this is
myself and nochi and then my advice at
the time frame daivam boo been hailed
golf who's right here and then Brendan
Murphy from Cambridge research so the
question really is in this you know
global economy you've got a lot of
international companies and sometimes
for
economic reasons or talent location
reasons there there may be some reason
to develop software in a distributed way
have different parts of your system
develop on different continents and
there's a lot of challenges that people
are aware of there's a lot of research
in this area but up until the time that
we studied this and since we published
our papers that have been other similar
studies later kind of know what is the
effect on code quality of having a very
distributed internationally distributed
software development project and so at
the time this is about a year after
windows vista came out well this is this
is a perfect case study windows vista
was developed on a number of continents
people around the world you want to
understand the effect of distribute
development let's let's look at what
happened with vista mecca maybe can give
us some insights so what we did was we
divided vista up into its constituent
components so think of individual
binaries with industry of shared
libraries you have applications like
notepad an explorer and for each of
these components we identified where the
developers were that made contributions
to these components so this is an actual
components en route dll and I've
anonymized the names but this actually
is the breakdown of the locations of
developers the numbers next to each
developers how many contributions have
any source code commits they made to the
code that went into CM route that DLL we
did this by mining data from the source
code repositories looking at changes to
source files and then what source files
were compiled into an individual dll and
the reason that we use this dll or the
binary level is that when microsoft
gives a bug reports we can tie them
fairly accurately down to the binary
it's not always easy to identify one
individual change or one individual
source code file that was the cause of
the bug so we did this for all of the
binders in this and there are thousands
of them and even if you can see the
percentage what we did was we we
categorize them into a number of
different levels based on how
distributed the developers were so if
the majority of the developers that
worked on a particular binary all work
in the same building they would
categorize the binary the building level
cafeteria one cafeteria microsoft can
serve a number of buildings but the use
of those buildings are in close
proximity cincy two-point-three percent
of the binaries had most of developers
from not in the same building what we're
in a tight group
buildings and then campus locality which
is like kind of a city suburban region
all the way to continent and then the
world level a world level means that we
couldn't identify any individual
continent that the majority of the
developers worked in so you'd have some
perhaps in Asia and others in North
America and others in Europe so this is
the breakdown and although the majority
are developed at the building level when
you have about three to four thousand
binaries even six percent at the world
level that's still a fair amount of
distribution so we have a number enough
samples at each level distribution that
if there's an effect we'd expect to see
something and our hypothesis at least
based on the prior literature is that as
the level distribution increases that'll
have a negative impact on quality
measure qualities is the number of bug
fixes that need to be made to individual
binaries and the way that we did this
was used standard method linear
regression standard method and
statistics and this is basically what I
data look like for every binary we had a
binary variable I shouldn't say by a
boolean variable the indicated the level
of distribution and we did this because
we didn't expect there's actually a
linear relationship between distance
between buildings and cafeterias
cafeterias and campuses we wanted to say
to determine if there's a particular
level we're above that level the quality
really diminishes greatly and in prior
research a lot of people have found that
if you that the number of developers
working on a particular piece of
software is strongly related to
post-release quality and we wanted to
control for that and that's why I
included the number of developers in our
models and this is the results of our
regression model so if you haven't seen
had to interpret it linear regression
models in the past I'll kind of break it
down for you each variable is quantifies
or each row represents the binaries that
were at that level of distribution and
the percent increase is the percent
increase the number of failures relative
to binaries that are developed by
developers in the same building so what
this means is de binary is developed by
developers and different campuses had on
average about six percent
more post Reese failures than binaries
that were developed by developers in the
same building and then the significance
the p-value on the right is the odds
gives you the probability that what
you're saying is just due to to noise in
the data or high amounts of variance so
when the p-value is below point 05 it's
kind of a magic cut off in statistics
that means that it's a statistically
significant result so for different
localities it looks like we have an
eight percent increase but the p value
of 0 point 457 means that there's so
much variance in the data that we're not
sure whether that's actually a real
effect or if it's just a function of not
having a large enough sample and so much
variance so there are only actually
three or two in this case two level of
distribution we're actually saw an
increase and although it's not trivial I
mean four percent is nothing to sneeze
at but it's not as high as we expected
we thought we'd be seeing increasing
posters failures of 2030 maybe a hundred
percent in terms of post rees failures
and we didn't see increased that high so
this is generally a good result we're
happy to see this but when we talk to
management people in Microsoft they said
well that's really surprising because
we've run into problems was distributed
development and so we kind of did an
informal survey of managers in windows
to see well how did howdy were you able
to do this do this level of distributed
development without a negative impact on
post release failures and this is the
list of things that they gave us I just
wanted to focus on on to the points that
they felt were perhaps the most
important I want to stress it we haven't
shown a cause relationship between any
of these points these are all kind of
hypotheses about what went on all of
these things went on during the windows
vista development cycle and that
managers believe had an effect on helped
in post release quality so almost daily
synchronous communication so I on a
daily basis teams would either come in
early or stay late so that teams on
different continents could communicate
in a synchronous usually like a video
chat say here's an issue that we need to
work on and that and that allowed them
to catch problems before they escalated
out of control by the end of the week or
at work the problems that escalated up
the management chain and became a real
issue so this lab then the catch things
early and deal with some of the
communication breakdowns that are often
associated with distributed development
in addition one of the problems that's
been mentioned in literature is if you
have teams in different places they may
use different tools or different
processes and so that works fine and
well while they're doing their own thing
but when it comes time to integrate all
their changes and release something you
run into major problems and that's what
leads to post release defects and also
delay and in Microsoft you have a number
of managers that started out in redmond
and then left and went to the individual
sites and they took with them the
process and they took with them and
understanding and knowledge of tools so
you have the same people in India or
choose me the different people in India
but using the same tools they're all
using the same source code management
system they're all doing bug triage in
the same way and by having this
consistency throughout the process they
avoided some of the problems that other
projects have shown so this is kind of
and there's a paper associated with this
and I'd be happy to talk about any of
these other points or any more details
of our analysis offline but it's kind of
a teaser to take a look and we're
actually interested in replicating this
study on some other projects both within
Microsoft and in the open source realm
actually so that was distributed
distributed excuse me geographically
distributed development we've also
looked at organizationally distributed
development so what's the effect of the
the structure of your organization and
how it develops source code and this is
motivated strongly by Conway's law which
is from the 60s so Connolly said the
organizations that design systems are
constrained to produce systems which are
copies of the communication structures
of these organizations and later in in
brooks sa very famous the mythical man
month he said that the quality of the
product is really affected by the
structure so so basically conway is
saying what you develop is going to look
like the structure the people and how
they work together and n brooke says you
know if you have a bad structure that's
going to lead to a bad product but oven
to this point there hadn't been some
empirical evidence so we decided to to
look at this question and so we also did
a study of again windows vista and what
we did is we came up with some
organizational metrics so let's say that
this is some product in microsoft and
it's over in redmond so we have peter
lee at the top and what
did was for every binary every component
within Windows Vista we identified where
are all the developers in the
organization that made changes to that
particular binary and they say well
let's look at how how cross-cutting
those developers are in the organization
so let's say that for one particular
binary you have developers in this
organism or this team and that team and
so one of our metrics goes how high up
and the management change you have to go
before you can find a common manager
over all the developers that contributed
to a binary we also look at how many
different organizations so it's a peter
lee is over here in redmond and andrew
blake who's the head of microsoft
research in cambridge there are some
developers under him that also make
changes to a binary so we counted how
many different organizations made
changes to a binary so this is just a
few of the metrics that we look the
number of Engineers that made edits to a
particular binary the number of
engineers who worked on a binary and
then left the organization often people
have some domain knowledge that's only
in their head and when they leave they
take or they take domain expertise with
them and that knowledge goes away and
leads to post release defects we
identified the organization the level
that we could fight i denti phi 75% of
ownership so if we had to go up three
levels versus one level lower levels of
ownership would lead to lower fewer
post-release failures the number of
edits made by the owning organization a
number of measures that tried to capture
how distributed across the organization
a particular binary is and then we built
a defect prediction model that basically
said what is relationship between these
measures and the quality of the software
and then we we looked at compared that
to prior studies so we have a long
history Microsoft using defect
prediction and I'll talk a little bit
next about why we do that we hear a
number of types of measures that we've
used so we use pre-release bugs so
what's the correlation between bugs
before you're released two bugs after
you release which relationship between
test coverage dependencies in the code
so these are a number of metrics for the
code and then the precision recall which
are just measures of accuracy for a
defect predictor what we found is that
when we look at the organizational
structure which is a measure of the
people not the code itself
the accuracy of a defect prediction or
rather relationship with post-release
failures is higher when looking at the
people than any actual measure of the
code so it appears that there's a very
strong relationship between the
organization that creates an entity and
the quality of that entity itself and
again this is so far it's been tested on
windows and a few smaller products I'd
like to replicate this on other in both
in other industrial context and also in
the open source context to see how how
universal this is and how specific it is
to Microsoft's I think it's important
when understanding empirical results to
to recognize the context because it may
not be universal but yeah I guess I
should have brought that up you saw a
strong relationship with with
organizational metrics than traditional
measures of software and then because so
I just showed you the results of some
defect prediction but we defect
prediction the fair amount in Microsoft
and the reason is that we want to ship
really high quality software but we
can't perfect software if you wait
till it's perfect you're never going to
get it out and so you're limited by both
time and by money and only have so many
people working on things we have to ship
at a certain date and so if you only
have a certain amount of time and money
what do you do well this is where defect
prediction can help if you can identify
the pieces of the software that are most
likely to have problems then you can
focus your time and your money on those
areas those are going to give you the
biggest bang for your buck and so the
standard thing that we do is we gather a
number of metrics so Sharon and
dependencies or standard metrics
organizational metrics I just described
to some metrics there's a number of
different type of metrics we feed that
into a machine learning model so we use
naive Bayes a district regression
principal component analysis and then
after we train that model on a subsample
maybe a prior release it develops in the
case of like logistic regression number
of coefficients and then we feed new
data into that model it makes
predictions sometimes in the form of
classifications will say this binary
will be defect prone and this one will
not and sometimes our ranking from top
to bottom here's the most defect prone
to
lease defect program and you can use
that to make decisions about how you're
going to allocate your resources to
improve your quality and so one of the
things that we I've in the King alotta
is is relationships between people and
artifacts and software so the number of
types of relationships one type of
relationships is by looking at
developers contributions so if we can
look at who's contributing to components
and cow components related related we
can be like a social network of
developers where the connections between
developers are actually how many items
they've worked on in common there's also
dependency relationships so for tube8
particular component you can see what
depends on that component and what
component does that what other
components is that component depend on
if you have all these types of
relationships and so the question that
we ask is you are the relationships and
topology the networks formed by these
relationships are they reflective of
actual failures post-release failures in
the field and so we did was we built
networks based on these relationships
and then used an area that actually
borrow from sociology called social
network analysis and social and social
network analysis or a number of forms of
centrality some of these you've probably
heard of if you have a network in this
case formed by pieces of software degree
centrality for each node is simply the
number of edges incident to that node
closeness centrality particular node
network is a measure of the distance
between that note and all other nodes in
the network between it is a measure of
how many of the shortest paths between
all doses Network a particular node lies
on I can factor sandtrout centrality is
computing actually the eigenvector of
the adjacency matrix and similar to what
Google uses for their PageRank algorithm
so there are some others as well these
are all measures of the importance of a
node in a network and they're all
measures that are on a per node and in
our case nodes in the network are
binaries and people so give you an idea
of what our networks look like we have
our developer relationships leads to a
contribution network so in this case
circles are binary and the rectangles
actually developers and we can build
this huge network and then look at the
social network analysis metrics for each
of the nodes of the network
and then also we have a dependency
network so dependencies are just based
on types defining one module are used in
another module inheritance relationships
RPC calls reading registry values that
another component rights method calls
and so that was our dependency network
and then we can combine them into what I
call a socio-technical network so this
has both people and their relationships
of software and the relationships
between individual software components
to build a network and so we did is we
build each of these individual networks
and then computed these centrality
measures and and here are the results so
precision and recall are both measures
of accuracy of a defect prediction model
and what we found was when we combine
both the social and the technical
relationships we got precision and
recall values of about point seven six
point seven which is high enough that we
can begin to use it to make resource
allocation decisions and so initially
what we found is the more information
you include the better your results will
be that may not actually always be the
case it can be the case that and when
you add additional measures your results
actually go your accuracy actually goes
down but we also decided to replicate
this on eclipse we did this when I was
in grad school so a Microsoft we don't
look at a lot of open source but I went
back to school and said well let's see
how well this works in other contexts so
free clips we gathered six releases and
in each case we would train the model on
one release and then evaluate it on the
next release and again a precision and
recall was actually afraid I even better
than in the case of Windows and so this
gives us confidence that this network
based prediction of building these
networks and then looking the
topological properties of the components
in these networks actually maybe more
general so far we've tested it on
windows and eclipse but you know for
universality we hope to be able to test
more things so that's that's kind of a
smattering of some of the things that
we've been doing in the area of socio
technical congruence looking at the
developer behavior and and what that can
tell us about software quality I'm going
to turn it over to
Tom now it's also a bug reporting triage
and data-driven suffer engineering uh
yeah actually we have I'm five minutes
ahead of time which I'm sure you're all
sad about so sure throw a few questions
at me okay so that's a really good
question so normally so in four
pre-release bugs that is the case we see
a really skewed distribution for
post-release bugs that actually is not
the case believe it or not and that this
is really kind of surprising because
most distributions don't look like this
in self engineering but it follows a
fairly normal distribution where you you
actually have like half of the binaries
actually have half of the books which is
surprising but there is a big difference
between the pre-release in the post
release bugs so yeah
yeah yeah so that's definitely the case
if a component is problematic and one
release it is almost always going to be
problematic in the next release yeah
there are cases where so the difference
is where sometimes there are no changes
to a component so if in release one
there's a lot of churn and then release
to no one changes anything then we don't
see as many post-release failures and
also there's new components that are
added to the system so obviously in that
case well we're building coefficients of
building a linear model based on data
from prior release we don't know
anything about that particular component
from the prior release because it simply
didn't exist and yet what the model has
learned actually is fairly accurate on
the data for the new components that
came into existence in the second
release
um so I think there has been some
is that what you guys did with Lloyd
Williams has a paper i think with that I
wasn't involved with but I think it
looked at like the relationship between
components that were had dependency
relationships with really buggy
components I believe the answer was yet
there was some relationship but that's
off the top of my head from that paper
I'd have to but you follow up with me
it'll be okay i can i can double check
on that any other questions for anyone
I've answered every question you want to
have great there feel free to talk to me
offline as well and Tom please people
might want to listen dear thanks so I'm
going to talk a bit about about buck
reporting and triage and I first want to
put the focus of it like on box and so
at mark sake of like lots of tools but
was of like many toys like we have vac
vacuums you have like many bugs and
because of like boxes we collect our box
and was of like watches where we can
observe box like how I behaved and the
reason why I'm showing this is like I
wanna show fat bugs are not just a big
thing for software developers for also
very big thing for kids and actually has
a one book which I like quite a bit so
it's called box box box and this book
has one special thing and it actually
comes with a bug tracker where children
can check for bugs that we found but we
observed in nature and I like this bug
tracker very much because it's the same
style as we use in software development
like you can see here it's essentially
Chester table we have like different
rows to describe above like for example
kids would like draw a picture of a bug
say if it would fly and if you think
about software development it's the same
except that we just have different names
for the columns like you asked for for
bugs like what are steps to recruit you
what's the type of a bug how was the
background who should be assigned to the
park and how severe losses work and
there's one difference for in software
development and fed to people because
software development bug tracking is a
highly collaborative process wife a bug
tracker photo showed you just for kids
it's usually just for one kid maybe for
parents but but that's it and so I don't
know like how many people of you have
life experience with bugs like who has
submitted a bug report ok who never got
anything about box okay so i can go
quickly oasis and this is just to give
you an idea like how bug tracking works
like essentially when you have a failure
in your software often what you get is
like you get an error message like
application keynote has unexpectedly
quit and what you can do then is like
you click on submit bug report and
depending on what kind of system you
have it might send a bug report
automatically but still many systems ask
for like manual back reports and that's
what you get for example if you file a
bug report for the apache web server you
get access pass here where you have to
first day which version how severe for
buggery is when used to provide a
description you add you can assign for
back to people and so on so this is like
the information for you as a user send
to a software developers this is how it
looks when in for bug database
essentially all fields of it in and pen
for canvas on some discussion about your
buck like in a public forum and also
bugs get assigned to people so this is
what I'm showing here exists buck would
be assigned to Steve so that's just to
set for common ground like but you know
what bug tracking is about and so one
thing which we did is we look like you
can imagine that the Microsoft buck
reports are quite center because that's
essentially where you get feedback from
customers and also very organized our
work and like one study which we did
like almost two years ago is with an
internal Philip go
we looked essentially which bugs
actually get fixed in Windows and so
when I talk to people many people are
surprised that not all bugs get fixed so
where some people are really shocked but
actually for often very very good
reasons not to fix a bug and so here a
few examples of bugs where you might
decide not to fix the bug for example if
you have a bug which occurs very rarely
and affects only few users like it
affects only Tom and her back is very
very expensive to fix like you have to
redesign entire Windows 10 probably
Microsoft won't fix the bug or like
actually quite a few empirical studies
which show that fixing box is much more
difficult than implementing new features
so for risk of introducing a back so i
think it was like most studies i talk
numbers like twice as risky as
implementing new features so that's why
user might decide not to fix a bug
because you might have to change a very
complicated piece of code and you
fearful might introduce new box or
sometimes it happens that people already
started relying on some existing
behavior and you cannot change the
behavior because hours you will break
the system so the research question that
we had is we essentially looked at
factors related to people and buck
report edits and we wanted to see if
there's some influence on on whether
bugs get successfully resolved as fixed
and there are two main reasons why we
were doing this because first it helped
us to identify inefficiencies in the
budgeting process sebastian is a process
about deciding which bugs get fixed and
baboon and it also helps to inform the
design of tools and policies for pop
triaging and just to give you one more
number why webcamming is actually quite
important so for windows we have about
2000 developers who write windows code
but if we look into the bug database for
windows at Microsoft for more than
24,000 Microsoft employees who
in some role participated in one bak
report for example a submitted a bug
report or provided feedback on a bug
report they were assigned to a bug
report of a test the bug report so you
can actually see that the number is much
higher and if you think about windows so
that's just for Microsoft employees who
submitted box but you can imagine like
Windows has like many many users and for
actually number of users who have an
interest in bug reports is much higher
so the methodology that we used was like
like what i call a sandwich so we
essentially had some qualitative survey
in the beginning committed some
quantitative data analysis in the middle
and we followed up with another survey
and the main question that we asked
initial survey was like in your
experience how to each of a set of
factors affect four chances of ever bug
will get successfully resolved as fixed
a new census to about 1,800 markers of
like Windows developers and out of em
like twenty percent responded and what
we did next is essentially we looked at
oil buck reports which were in the
windows vista database so unfortunately
i can't tell you how many but it was
quite a bit and we looked at certain
factors like how does reputation of a
buck reporter in fact for chances of a
buck getting fixed what about the
interest in a buck report for a number
of reassignments and for distance and
yeah so let me show you some results so
the first thing which we looked at was
at reputation and this was partly
motivated by one of the quotes that we
got back from finishes away and for
quota is a big influence on bug fixes is
a reputation of a person opening for bug
if the submitter has a high history of
submitting high quality box for new box
from personal get better attention okay
so if you have a high history if you
have a history of submitting hi
d bugs that's good for your buck report
so that's essentially what you use to to
quantify for reputation so essentially
for each buck report we looked at the
person who submitted for back report we
checked how many bugs did the person
open in the past okay and we checked how
many of these bugs were actually fixed
and what we molested is we computed for
percentage of fixed box so you can see
here as like a plus one so it's not
exactly four percentage so four plus one
was fair for two reasons like first it
avoids division by zero so that's the
obvious reason but for more stuff is
like more subtle reason is essentially
it also introduces some waiting because
if you think of a person we have
submitted one buck report which was
fixed what if a person ends up is with
one over tool so if 0.5 compared to a
person with 100 buck reports of which
all 102 fixed you have 100 over 100 1 so
it's a much higher value and so what we
essentially found is so fat sphere aside
I'm not trying for a socket but
essentially on for x axis you can see
for reputation of a person who opened
the buck and onto y axis you see the
likelihood federer bug was fixed so
unfortunately I cannot show you through
y axis further labels but I'm sure you
can figure it out in essentially what
you found is essentially if it was
almost like a perfect correlation
between the reputation of a buck opener
and fit chances fit box get fixed
because what you can see here is like if
you have a very low reputation live was
a very low likelihood of your bug
reports getting fixed compared to when
you have a very high reputation it's
very likely that your bug gets fixed
there were few exceptions I for example
if you submit your first buck report
then your your argued of the bucket
getting fixed would be
here so another thing which we looked at
was at reassignments and like actually
quite a few people in research think
like four three assignments are bad and
fed Fae actually decrease the chances of
bugs getting fixed and we email like a
question our survey to her Microsoft
developers and favored the same so we
asked like how does the Buckra
productivity affect your chances of
being successfully fixed no reassignment
developers for it increases our chances
if you have many reassignment decreases
the chances so what we found was
actually not exactly assists it was
slightly different so we found fit for
Louis likelihood for bugs getting fixed
is actually when you have no
reassignments okay for a few
reassignments it increases with a cute
of bugs getting fixed and then it starts
decreasing again and so fair was one
actually two reasons but this is a case
and like one is essentially for buck
report reassignments essentially part of
a process i get microsoft when you have
a bug report and usually someone fixes
it when it gets tested and then it might
go back to the developer for additional
work but essentially usually multiple
people are involved for successful bug
fix and another thing is like vets would
I BF a quote here is that often bugs are
submitted to different components like
for example here many bucks many times
are exposed in the user interface but
are not caused by the team writing for
UI code fees bucks can pass down several
layers of components before landing on a
lower level component owner so in each
of these levers corresponds to one
reassignment
info survey we also asked about like our
factors which influenced her chances of
bucks getting fixed and like one which
was pointed out was the quality of a
pocket part so if you have a good
quality Park report higher chance of
getting fixed poor quality lower chance
of getting fixed and now one was for
customer and business impact so if if
it's a very high cost of not fixing for
back then it's more likely to be fixed
also how senior or how high up the buck
opener is that think of having a vice
president who submits a buck report
compared to an intern submits a bug
report so vet has some some influence
and also for interpersonal skills
remember I told you it's like a highly
social process but fixing essentially
what sometimes needs to happen is that
people need to argue for a bug report so
we need to convince the person who's in
charge charge of fixing the bug ysis bug
should be fixed and essentially what
came out of the sea search roses we came
up with a set of recommendations for how
to to improve the box washing process
like one was essentially if it needs to
be some training for employees to right
high quality bug reports and not only
needs to be restored raining you also
need to have some incentive so incentive
like like what some projects in open
source it is like they'd like some
special prize for the best back report
and yeah also you need to increase
awareness of developers because often
like why we showed four three
assignments are not necessarily bad for
still quite a large number of your
assignments that happen for no good
reason because sometimes I just don't
know who should fix the bugs were just
assigned the bug report to Chris and
Chris Van just says hey it's not my book
science it back to me
also communication and just suffice
related like fits also very important
thing to improve and also it should be
very objective in which box guitar
priority than ours I pre if you want to
do a shout out to a related study we
also look at what makes a good buck
record and professor journal paper if
you're interested is this one so now
briefly want to talk about data driven
soft engineering so this is to connect
to work from Shorty's keynotes this
morning and they essentially many
different questions that you look at in
a computer software engineering group so
here just a few of em so for actually
more and essentially what we use for to
answer these questions is a combination
of mining software repositories so i'm
not sure like if you haven't heard of
mining software posit or is essentially
what diseases you take like existing
repositories like the version control
system for bug database and you apply
some sort of data mining technique to
get some insight out of repositories and
also like another area where we use many
techniques from is empirical software
engineering and if you think about this
like the way i usually explain it is
like mining software repositories this
focus a lot more on ottoman or two on
doing things automatically while in pure
software engineering is here you're
focused on getting insights like getting
very deep inside and i think it would be
important to essentially combine these
two areas and move on to software
development analytics and svet suicide
from wolfram Wolfram's keynote so
essentially the definition of analytics
is quite interesting because it's very
open like if you look at this one here
it says use of analysis data and
systematic reasoning to make decisions
okay
so if you look at it like it's so
analysis can be anything right you can
do some data mining you can use some
statistical techniques you can survey
people you can interview people same for
data you can use almost any data to make
decisions and you can use almost any
reasoning technique so pretty much
almost everything can fall insisted
insisted finishin but for its 11 key
point in this definition and fetes to
make decisions so we do all this
analysis to make decisions and as we're
from pointed out like these areas are
very successful in using data to make
decisions but in software engineering I
think we still need to catch up a bit
and so so here's like one but i think is
quite some success story in analytics
which is essentially web analytics and
faye we call it web analytics two point
oh and if you think about how web
analytics looked like 15 years ago like
when i started using for web like what
many people here it was like these
counters like so many people went to my
web page so that's what you all that's
what modest analytics at this time also
get a web page we at a counter you may
be broke it down by that page maybe by
country but all you got was like a
report but if you look at it now
actually very sophisticated tools which
allow you to interactively show you down
into four data slice it and dice it and
very different ways and it's not just
this what changed web analytics they
also realized that it's not just
measurement right I don't know like if
you if you browse the web what sometimes
happens is is that you get like an
invitation to participate in a survey so
essentially if it's also what we
realized is we need more more
qualitative data so if we need to get
feedback from customers however use the
web pages to to build better web pages
and again I think that's something which
is missing
in lots of decision making right now so
coming back to software development
analytics so there are two observations
I think it's observations essentially
like one like the first one is at stake
holders have very different needs like
many people in research think like from
a research perspective developed
developer perspective but really there
are many other people are you have
testers you have development leads you
have test needs and you have managers
who all want to get out something out
out of data but they all ask very
different questions and most researchers
are just focused on developers or some
people are just focused on testing but
not many people think about all of them
and also like essentially what's this
hint said is that you need different
rules for different stakeholders but I
think you need to go go one step further
is actually need to have different tools
for the same kind of stakeholder and
Cisco goes back to the measurement and
and qualitative insights thing but
essentially if you just look at
measurement there's only so much you can
find out like for example you can find
out that some metric has changed
yesterday dramatically but you don't
really know why has it changed and so
you also like you always have like to
select two kinds of questions like first
what has happened and why I 70 and so
essentially a single tool won't be
enough so in short I think like what the
direction is like we need to make for
data that we collect right now more
actionable and also more accessible and
46 different directions where think we
can go like first it's essentially about
the data collection like lots of
research is very data focus especially
in South mining software repositories we
take a few repositories we come up with
a great research question we come up
with a great tour and we hope that
someone is starting using it
but really the way that it should be
should be the other way around we start
with the people you want to find out
what we need and if anything about what
data do we need to collect so that's one
direction for data collection and via
one is essentially for integration of
different data sources because that now
we have like buck databases we have
version archives of communication if all
kinds of documents and they're not very
tightly integrated in our direction is
essentially data quality and that's
where the christed some very great
research if you think about it you want
to make a decision and you want to base
your decision on data and if you do so
fanvid quality of a data should be
really good because if a quality is bad
you might end up doing the wrong
decision just because the data was wrong
so having statuses it doesn't mean that
you need to have one hundred percent
correct data for example if you don't
use certain data to make decisions and
the quality of the stator doesn't really
matter of it much another direction is
privacy because yet data came used to
make many decisions and many decisions
also involved like people like at
workplaces and so I think it's about
time to start thinking about about
privacy the fourth one is essentially
about understanding for user needs
so this picture here shows it
essentially if the organizational
structure of a company so I think most
like a research were really really good
on this level like we know a lot about
developers what fer needs are like what
tools they need I would argue that we
don't know too much about managers okay
and especially we don't know a lot about
the communication that takes place
between the different levels and that's
where typically data is used to to make
decisions like a manager uses some data
to communicate a decision that is made
our to his managers or two as reports
fee fifth direction is this essentially
for user experience that you can have a
great result or great finding but as
long as you can can present it to use it
in a intuitive way they probably won't
act on the on finding so it's really
about like thinking about how can we
surface information what's the best way
to visualize insults and 46 Direction is
essentially a thing for education
because there's a huge interest in
society right now to to become what a
turd rim and I think it's also important
for us to teach engineers like how to
how to look at it or how to analyze data
how to understand research results and
that concludes the talk if you are
interested in our quote our webpage
thing for it imperia soft engineering at
microsoft and thank you very much
yeah you the puck yeah so we looked at
you mean like which box should be fixed
or not and so we did an evaluation but
the thing is so turn out to be fairly
okay i think was like seventy percent
precision seventy percent recoil but it
was quite as some pushback on using such
models and essentially like like first
like every buck is kind of unique right
it's very hard I don't think we should
go for making decisions about which bugs
should be fixed in an automatic fashion
so that some of the person needs to look
at and that's also what most developers
opinion was
I mean like like one of reasons why we
pitch this module was mostly to
understand for interaction between four
different factors so you could use it
for protection but it's not necessary
for best thing to do yeah yeah people
could use it but I think it's not a
positive because it essentially like
four factors which contribute to Weber
box should be fixed like first you want
to look like what's the impact of about
how severe is about how much would it
cost to to fix the bug and I think how
many how many users are affected and
fetes something which which is very hard
to capture automatically so that's why
you can't automate this process yeah
can you repeat yeah
I guess if I some tools for food to
placate detection I don't have any
studies at Microsoft but was quite a lot
of research in an open source yeah no
not Microsoft but for some like first
some is actually at FSC 2009 there was
for debug advisor to it so that's like
one to which people use for pho to
placate detection
so we're different databases the boxes
are stored at Microsoft so you have like
the cough park database which is used
for development if any of the customer
submitted pocket database and
essentially if a bug like bugs from the
customer database then get propagated to
for bug database no no like customer
bugs are really important so it's yeah
there are probably more important when
PvP because the VP shop might make us
decisions based on what customers what
yeah
so I don't don't have any numbers winces
but like we make the same observation
like if you have for more information
you provide for them more likely it is
that your bug pit sticks so think we did
some studies like like before I joined
Microsoft I looked at partying in open
source and very found back if he likes
tech traces or code example examples
like your livelihood increases
dramatically fit above gets fixed
so first one quote the patrols poisk
actually a kisses if like if you make
like your UI for submitting box ten
percent easier to use you get twice as
many bug reports so first I would say
yes probably but fester like a trade-off
because if you make it easy for everyone
to submit a bug report when you might
get way too many so if you want to
submit back reports to Microsoft go to
connect ok so what Microsoft now being
shown how it is done in Germany we look
very much
actually happened because DJ and I
happen to be in Australia at the same
time having a beer and I said well if
you do what about if you come to Paris
thanks to this first it confirms again
my statement that all my important
collaboration started with a beer
secondly let me thank you to this for
the invitation because I really enjoyed
it and I chose it most of all because
it's a very interesting extension of the
communities I'm usually going to it was
interesting to he to find here lots of
people i have seen for and met for 10 20
years but also people i've never met
before and that's a very nice extension
and south got feedback and information
from different perspectives that i'm
usually getting it which is always
helpful so my talk is also an empirical
studies or an empirical soft engineering
and it's probably most closely connected
to the data trends of gengineering i
have been involved in software
development studies software engineering
studies of all kinds for many years I
worked for ten years in the software
engineering lab at NASA which I always
call the mother of all empirical apps
and I have continued doing this in
kaiserslautern for many years but still
and I apologize for this because that
might be due to my age or experience I'm
still little bit frustrated about the
overall impact of the studies we are
doing so we are doing nice studies but
overall in terms of overall guidance for
software development practice or also
education not that much improvement has
been made you know I always envied my
engineering colleagues because when they
talk about physical laws and the
students don't believe it they go to the
lab then they believe it immediate
feedback when I talk about what I call
software engineering Los they go to the
lab and do it differently and you know
what the program might even work so they
don't believe really that well what I
told them and the reason is that our
lost and that's what I call cognitive
loss also I know I'm real getting in
trouble with
the cognitive community with that for
that but I don't care anymore it is that
they have a tremendous time lag so it
might work actually right now and you
made some valid points but sometimes you
better never touch the software again or
if you have to change it year down the
road then you finally find out that you
actually violated some law or some rule
or some guidance but you didn't see this
at the time when you're developing so
what I would like to do is actually to
say how can we take the next step and
not only branch out into more studies
which is certainly necessary and some of
the things you highlighted but also how
can we create more quality kind of
evidence out of these studies that
eventually will believe and will become
the core of the signs of software
engineering so that a developer if you
don't adhere to that you are guilty of
negligence so if you're not following
these guidelines it's okay to take the
responsibility but then you take the
responsibility today it's the other way
around I'm very often in front of courts
when people are fighting and typically I
mean it's amazing how people from
companies argued that there are no
guidelines we had to invent the wheel
again yeah so how where they come from
we have lots of these empirical results
but we have not thought about how much
of this is only locally relevant how
much can we integrate maybe it's it's
it's valid for a domain for type style
of system or maybe even if you think as
a scientist for our entire discipline
they also we have lots of says we'll
leave level kinds of results but we
haven't aggregated them or made any
effort to move towards that direction
now you will see of course that the
problem is that an hour feel there is so
many potential factors that you will
never be able to cover everything so I
think we will never get to Los if the
expectation is you have done enough
experiments covering all possible kind
of context situations this is my ongoing
fight with Dave farmers who keeps
telling me you shouldn't do
experimentation is of engineering
because you will never do a good
experiment from a physical point of view
that's correct we will never be doing
experiment where all the variables are
covered enough so maybe and that site we
are a little bit more on the social
science side that we have to decide
based on our understanding what are the
important impact factors have to cover
them and then have to basically by
community decision say now that's enough
evidence to say this should be a
guideline or rule for us to follow so it
will never be the complete formula proof
by means of experimentation what's the
expectation from some people from
physics so let me go into this and start
with a small motivation which is
hopefully not too much recap and then
contrast a little bit very briefly
traditional engineering software
engineering and then I will talk a
little bit about this distinction
between observation laws and theories
where I see the trend may be going and
finally I would like to excite you a
little bit about a new activity we are
trying to start and maybe you might even
be interested to join us so motivation
obviously engineering requires among
other things I am not covering
everything here that we do understand
and then we can predict otherwise we
will not be able to do data-driven
software engineering and if we know some
of the constraints that we can scale
engineering based on regularities yeah
so we we are very bad in scaling in the
sense that's the result is what you
describe that certain critical modules
you better never touch again because
they were not designed for change they
were not designed for testing they were
just designed to provide a certain
functionality maybe I should tell you
why I'm maybe on a more strict side here
I'm coming actually from the embedded
system world and in a better software
systems you have to provide quality of
service guarantees it's not valid enough
to say we did our best or it was better
you there is certain levels of quality
you have to be able to guarantee so if
you want to do this you have to have a
process product relationship but
engineer say I have to use methods tools
whatever of which I know kind of what
their impact is on what my quality goal
is now now you could argue so stay with
embedded systems now unfortunately
we don't have that distinction anymore
between a better system to information
systems we are this nice dude label
cyber physical systems we are merging
them more and more that means that's no
longer something you can just do in the
side of a better systems it will become
a challenge for all kinds of critical
and social whatever systems we are
developing as long as they are in the
related in some way with embedded
systems so traditional engineering
disciplines do this based on physical
laws and as I said I always envied them
because the feedback is very quick
software engineering partially uses
empirical models we have some of them we
are using mostly limited to very
constrained domains and the question is
that the key question could they
eventually define the I believe
cognitive laws in our field so what we
need to do is we need to expand
empirical studies to our relevant
process or a product areas by means of
replication you mentioned some you
mentioned some things that you would
like to replicate the somewhere else why
because then scientifically you have
more evidence or better evidence we
might have to aggregate them to go from
small processes to large processes I
remember at the time when I was at
Maryland we wanted to introduce together
with IBM at the time I'm sorry for that
term here in in the context of a
Microsoft building but we wanted to
introduce with Harland Mills a cleanroom
development and of course you know you
cannot do a real controlled or a
reasonably controlled study on a such a
huge process so what was the approach we
thought what are the critically new
aspects like using inspection for
testing and so on and so we did
controlled experiments on the critical
things which we thought were the
inhibitors for acceptance and then
aggregated the stuff and did only case
studies on the entire process I think
that's one way of dealing with larger
processes you will never be able to run
controlled experiments for huge
development processes just the time lack
and so on the lack of control and so is
impossible yeah we have to do this until
we become they become qualitatively
stable
what I mean with qualitatively stable is
we will never have life in physics that
the use of a technique has exactly that
as effect there will always be variances
because you're using a different context
but I am tempted to call it along if the
use of something always has a positive
or always has a negative impact there
are so for instance in my environment we
did lots of studies on inspection
techniques for requirements and
eventually a technique showed always
positive impact sometimes it was only
ten percent reduction of rework
sometimes was 50 it depended a little
bit on the context of the company but we
didn't have and other people replicated
this never a country counter example and
so we were tempted to say that's from
our point of view a law that if you
develop software in this domain yeah use
inspections for requirements of that
point you will have a better positive
impact on quality and rework reduction
or or cost yeah now I'm not sure whether
we can get much better because there's
always kinds of differences in different
areas but I think that's a much stronger
statement dentures listing 25 studies
and saying look we have done this 25
times it looks like a simple application
but it says something so that every
software developer who says I want to
achieve certain quality or I want to
reduce rework has to be aware there is a
technique that you should use to reduce
this if you don't use it you take
responsibility and if it doesn't work
you should justify your decision like
other engineers to it's reversing the
responsibility not I as a research also
have to convince you that you should use
this now its body of our not our body of
knowledge and if that's your goal you
should use it or you have a good reason
for not doing it yeah we know there is
always situations which not justified
but then you take the responsibility
yeah that's what a body of knowledge
means yeah also in building or when
other engineering people don't do always
the same things but they know if the
risk is that you should use certain
techniques otherwise you are in danger
of getting into court if a building
crumpets so we need more then of course
we need notations link which is methods
and tools now should we discussed this
morning or after the meeting we have
heard so much about languages in the
context of this meeting how much
knowledge do we have which languages
which type of languages are actually
accepted and easily usable by normal
developers of different kinds we make
our assumptions we ask the developers of
languages we like that and think it's
good yeah but how much knowledge do we
really have to justify things like
functional versus imperative or whatever
maybe yeah what is the normal developer
whether it's a sophisticate or less
sophisticated capable of using because
if they don't want to use it if we
talked about user experience too if they
don't want to use it if they can't use
it yeah the result will be bad yeah I
always remember how they've partners
told me how easy the four variable model
is the true if you are part of the team
yeah I haven't seen that many
organizations with 500 5000 developers
to use it because it's simply not
revered use it now we as scientists
researchers very often think if we can
use it effectively it's ready for
rollout and there is a big step in
between which empirical studies I
believe can cover but in the end all
notations methods into which we are
using in an organization the critical
ones at least we should know under what
circumstances what effects we do have
now this I want to make very sure very
short I mean in physics and this picture
is not important it's just giving a
visual impression of regularity we know
that the physical large item and I told
you before that's the key for scaling
engineering now if you look at this you
get a visible recognition of there is
something like divide and conquer you
could understand this entire thing by
understanding modules and then composing
them in some kind of predefined ways and
you could imagine if I need for more
course how this could look like if I
need that and this is true for all kinds
of
physical artifacts now physics not
physics engineering practices they have
organized themselves in three layers
also in research also in universities
everywhere you have always some
underlying mathematics you have the
scientific area in this case saying it's
physics yeah and then you have the
application of these laws in engineering
practices yeah I actually believe one of
the problems we do have is we don't know
what is science and what's engineering
in our field well mix this very much and
you have to cabrillo science department
which are completely on the scientific
side and you have cabrillo science
departments which are completely on the
engineering side so software engineering
you get a physical impression that these
dividing Congress used here yeah this is
by the way a real system there about 10
million lines of code for microsoft that
might not be extremely high but for us
this is a bit a reasonably big system
and we very often do a reverse
engineering we have tools for that to
show the structure and fit visibly
convince people why they might have a
problem maintaining that system this was
a system which I will not mention the
name of which every new release the
system went down for one week they
couldn't tolerate this and so eventually
we try to convince them that this was
not an isolated problem this was a
general problem in addition we found out
that the system had 4,000 violations of
the actual architecture this is the
actual architecture and the specified
architecture so if you came as a new guy
on board to maintain the system and you
looked at the documented architecture
you better throw it away it might
mislead you more than help yeah so is a
big problem how we deal with the
concepts of design for testability
design for more ability more
availability is not established in our
field and this is what I said before the
guys can go out of my class some of them
at least go into the lab hack something
violating all the things we talked about
and it works at some point in time by
it's only a question of time until you
should never touch this again and by the
way
do not believe that something
considering this does increase costs on
the country yeah I have always
experienced in my entire professional
life if you do the right thing it costs
less yeah unless you do over-engineering
i'm not talking about over-engineering
it just doing the project you want to do
the right way and so empirical studies
to some extent also help visualization
is an important part of measurement
there because very often the data itself
is not self explanatory you may use some
kind of visual metaphor so to convey
that to people in a better way and this
helps actually to get some of this
across now how do how are we organized
now that's from my point of view how we
should be organized we also need some
kind of mathematics is slightly
different large amount of discrete
mathematics but not only this from my
point of view computer science is
whatever the foundations are the science
we are not clear on that and the
application of this in building large
artifacts that ignore the other one one
important reason I believe in that
structure is when we develop systems or
involved it's very hard to speak to
engineering people if you don't have
kind of a similar view of your area its
hardware software and either we are
talking about science or we talk about
engineering this kind of structure is
much more helpful for this today in most
departments this is in the same
department yeah and it depends a little
bit on the history some were created out
of mathematics some more from Electrical
Engineering knife extent a snake in
German and they have different
perspectives on things now what's the
realm of empirical studies here does it
belong here or here it depends yeah I
mean even in my very basic work we do in
that case mostly controlled experiments
to have a first understanding of what we
are doing has certain benefits but on
the other hand engineering should never
be done without learning something so we
are
claiming that every project should be
viewed as a case study to piggyback on
it some things I want to learn otherwise
it's a waste from that point of view
modeling because imperious studies is
one thing but what are the models you
are creating relevant for a domain or
relevant for the community at large
again you have the same thing I mean
here in computer science we do a
modeling we are trying to understand for
instance in your case or in case of
testing you have different techniques
you are developing how well are they
working so by means of controlled
experiment but if you want to do this
for organizations for instance the body
of knowledge from Microsoft or for
Siemens whatever or even larger then
this is something that will take place
based on lessons from engineering so in
previous studies and modeling is part of
the science aspect of our field as well
as the engineering now this here I only
put up to say no excuses accepted that
we can do this I mean we have 25 years
of history that we can do experiments
purely experiments I'm now using for
control as well as case studies that we
can do that the hindrance is typically
not the technology the message we do use
but it is a I would say the
understanding that something like this
is needed especially in companies I have
a lot to do with were engineers are
running company where you would expect
that they are very close to something
like this but they don't understand this
kind of experimentation and support it
very well by the way these are just our
methods we are using for setting up
measurement programs so a lot what you
said about stakeholders privacy that's
exactly why we developed this because we
said it's not enough to say what do you
measure you have to have that context or
how do you pick it back a case study on
a real project is this q IP or how to
organize and package this so we have
tools in place and I'm not saying these
are the only ones I'm saying there are
tools if you are using something similar
that's fine too
studies and built models so how do they
look like I mean I apologize I do this
in a nutshell what I'm saying is for
prediction models and think for instance
of the Kokomo model predicting effort
based on size you are typically trying
to predict something related to quality
productivity or time in this case it was
cost and the model was a model of the
life cycle of the entire development
process so you have an effort model for
that and you want to predict it based on
a model this a 2 would be in terms of
kokomo system model to capture size in
the lines of code or some kind of
complexity and you predict the impact of
this on cost depending on some
independent variables I call this
context so it's different whether you
have experienced people as experience is
different whether you are in a large
system environment small system
environment what all these impacting
factors might be and I put here hidden
context because one thing we have
learned if we have very valid model from
one environment and another environment
and we really understand well the impact
if we try to merge them suddenly things
that we're constant here in constantia
become variable if you merge it and you
screw the entire result so that's a very
important aspect we use qualitative
analysis of Chris for this you can't
always do this quantitatively if we try
to build larger models now I don't
explain all this just a few things the
prop the relationship is obviously not
deterministic because we are focusing on
human-based kind of processes most of
them are human based and the variance
which is here indicated plus minus five
or ten percent depends on that you have
enough sufficient number of data points
that you have captured all the
independent variables and that the ones
you are not capturing our reasonably
stable yeah then you can get a
reasonably stable prediction for
instance we have for many companies in
Germany done destroy inspections where
blast minus five percent is not
impossible it's a few cycles of learning
and you have a very stable prediction
model now we use as I said qualitative
analysis to find these hidden context
vectors when you merge things and
obviously the variance can increase
again if we do this so we have hidden if
we have these hit in context variables
and so what you do if you two things we
do the same thing we do for product
lines if we try to merge two and realize
the span is too white then we do to
product lines the same here if we merge
it and the variance gets too high we
keep them as two separate models then
obviously the difference is too big to
throw them under one umbrella so but er
nothing new that's the same thing we
have done for years in architecture and
product line engineering so what for
what for what scope of projects or
products do you have one reference
architecture and when is it more like
more more helpful or more efficient to
have to reference architectures now most
of the empirical models of this kind and
this is a small sum of this form of
partial functions so for different kinds
of context sets you have different
results so frames the testing technique
and let's say you were interested in the
percentage of defects you find you find
85% if you have a certain limited code
complexity and the experience of people
is high and you might have different
kinds of results if it's different now
this is however very valid description
for someone defining a project because
if you define a project you have goals
and constraints the engineer asks I want
to achieve that goal and I have the
following constraints give me a process
that works so you would go hindi I have
to build the projects we're based on my
process model I want to find eighty-five
percent I have experienced developers
and we have guidelines in place that the
code complexity stays below a certain
level then this technique gives me a
certain result yeah if not i use
something else if i don't find something
i do hypothesis based overall you can
imagine if you think about these
predictive models you can have four
kinds where you relate product aspect to
product aspects let's say
something in the earlier phase two later
phase product process process process
and process product this is really the
one that is most closely related to
these processed product relationships
every engineer talks about so for
instance the the test model here is one
of that kind now what exists today I
think most people would say not enough
what do I mean by observations laws and
theories to put this into context
observations are I have done one study
and I have no idea whether i will repeat
the trend nor the quantitative result if
i do it one more time at least i don't
know yeah that's what i call observation
one single point i call it the law if i
have a representative set of studies and
what's representative I mean community
people who understand that domain have
to decide did I cover all critical
aspect or not that's what I said before
mitochondria bday upon us we will not be
able to cover everything yeah and I'm
sure reasonably certain that I have
qualitative stability so what I said
before it will always be better or
always be worse not quantitatively if
you want to have quantitative stability
you really need to have a theory which
means you have you understand all
impacting factors that's really a long
way to go yeah we don't have that many
theories except for very very very
constrained areas my goal is to move
during my lifetime and so this has to
happen pretty quickly I'm already one of
the older guys here at least have a set
of what are the 20 laws like for
instance what Barry babe always said
that if you find the effect early they
are cheap so if you have this problem
use a certain inspection technique you
will always buy your quality in reduced
effort how many of these can we find
that we can say they should be on a
short list of every developer and either
you satisfy them
or you have better you better have a
good reason why not to do it so what
exists are today almost mostly
observations we have some laws but we
need more of the latter one so the
existing body of knowledge there is a
lot we have developed experienced basis
for ourselves for our technologies we
are selling but also together which
companies for instance bush together
there is an empirical lab where they try
to develop these models for all their
what they call best practices it's
amazing they call the best practice
before the new world their best but
there are already best practices and now
we are trying to substantiate this or
qualify this there's also a large body I
once did an effort with a colleague of
mine to write together things and it's
amazing how many facts exists but still
we need to do more and we have to make
sure that we don't have these little
areas there is a little bit of Microsoft
experience there's a little bit of
Siemens experience and so on this does
not this helps companies but it does not
add to the body of knowledge for us as a
community which I would like to see
reflected in teaching as well as in
general practices so eventually in front
of a court I would like to be able to
apply these criteria if someone says I
have done a good job because if you
haven't applied them you haven't done a
good job make if you're an example VW
had a problem that a child got killed
because the front seat the baby seat the
air back was sharp into the child died
now the excuse was the guy brought the
car to earth to a shop the battery was
taking off they were head back on and it
went into default mode mode which was on
the rug now I would say if you build
software for that safety-critical
systems you should know about reach
ability analysis define critical States
and guarantee that they can't be reached
now these people didn't even know about
these techniques yeah so I'm just saying
from a professional point of view they
should not be involved in this kind of
software and it's amazing that with all
their lawyers they can get around this
in front of a court
so I skip this just to have a view you
can actually through our internet site
for all the techniques this is for
instance how we apply this safe this is
the tool that we engineers reverse
engineers the architecture which you now
can apply life so anytime you make a
programming decision the system tells
you whether you violate the specified
architecture yeah and so we have given
make evaluations all these are
evaluations with industry customers and
there is a whole list of this so
everything we are offering at least we
are trying to do the job experimental
software engineering means not
experimentally building software it
means we bring things to the lab to
experiment with them so we can go to
customers and have a certain sense what
they're good for and bad and my
experience is we are reducing the gap
for introducing new things by that to a
point through a company thinks it's
manageable they don't feel like they're
guinea pigs anymore they have some
evidence I mean we can provide a hundred
percent evidence because other than we
would have to do the studies in their
context so I'm not going through this
there is a large number of things I
would I could talk about but this is
something we can also see in the
internet maybe this as a reference i'm
using this v model for experimentation
for all my PhD students not only yeah so
they follow this model they have to
based on state of the practice analysis
you find a problem a hypothesis then
they have to think about one solution
approach they'll think about the problem
is a camp companies have too much rework
then you say one way of addressing this
is defining a new inspection technique
that finds more defects then you do your
research develop this and then you
experiment the first isn't technology
focused experiment where you compare
this to others in a controlled way
whether you find more defects but then
you integrate it into the development
process of this domain and see whether
because there's lots of things that can
have a benefit in isolation they will
not have a benefit when you integrate
them so this is the controlled
experiment mostly controlled experiment
not
exclusively and this is then more case
studies we do in conjunction with our
industry partners now this is the book I
wrote many years ago and there are
things described which we call laws or
whatever term you want to use and some
of them look very obvious but the point
was that it's not being followed up on
them so if you say requirements
deficiencies are the prime source of
project failures there is a certain
domain behind us I have year only listed
the references then there is possible
solutions now it would be nice if I
would of course have models that say do
I have inspections what do I have
different inspections and know which one
is better then we are really in
engineering we make choices about
process based on facts now also
inspections we have lost but what I
would like to close ways to not run out
of time too much is we are currently
really trying to put together an effort
to take a first step into aggregation
and we are trying to find several
companies probably within the domain we
have very large projects in Germany
where we have aerospace automotive and
so on several companies that are guinea
pig so to speak where we do experiments
for Francis model driven development and
the idea is you can do this as different
levels you can do this for a research
organization so I like we did it for our
competencies you could do it for
Microsoft Research what about you do you
could do it for development organization
which is already more complex but the
focus here we would be four key
processes they used in their development
or maybe new ones they want to introduce
and really what what I try to pitch he
is we want to go beyond one company we
want to work towards community at large
loss and so we have already convinced
Springer who wanted to write half a
second edition of our book and I said
you know the purpose of the book was to
just show there is enough already it's
not the right media 22 may
maintain the body of knowledge so now
what we are doing is actually not
writing your book but they will maintain
a version where companies can buy not
the entire book but something related to
a technology to a domain and in the
background they will actually host a
database to continue evolving this so we
would probably be a responsible for
content management and when do you just
call something a long as I said before
there has to be some accepted PS from
let's say the design inspection testing
community who say to make it a law for
this domain or in general we have
covered all bases enough to make that
judgment call I mean this is by the way
very often done in medicine now social
sciences where you could never come to a
conclusion if you would wait for
complete coverage yeah so you have to
have experts who say if you have covered
that that is grounds for saying we think
in general this applies they might be
won't wrong once in a while otherwise
nobody would die of medication but in
most of the cases they might be right
now I see this as the only way if you
want to go from the huge set of little
plants of empirical evidence to
something that will shape our discipline
in more general terms and will not do
this in one step so when I say here
community at large of course that's too
much we want to capture let's say with
five or ten companies in one domain
that's the idea and so there's lots of
questions here of course I believe the
time is right to shift to the next year
we need more to do more studies but I
think we also need to elevate this who
wants to participate actively I mean and
the most important thing is because I
have been involved in several smaller
experiments like this or activities like
this how do you provide the incentive
for others to participate to contribute
reflections new insights whatsoever
because here we have to have quality of
user we have to user experience we have
to make it nice and this might be
something actually besides the empirical
stuff but Microsoft concur
contribute something so we can't have a
standalone tool really say input your
experiences that's not going to work it
has to be part of something else that is
a side effect and that is fun there
might be reward there might be something
that makes it exciting for people to
contribute also what they get back in
terms of accumulated experiences so this
is my plan for the next five years I'm
not sure whether it will succeed but I
certainly willing to take an effort to
bring this to the next level thanks a
lot I mean first of all probably take a
large representatives domain within
Microsoft and do it but that would be
more for Microsoft you have lots of
individual experiences lying around so
the speaker but how many of these are
really used by what would it take for
practitioners to take to pick this up
yeah so it's more in terms of we
understand but how do you make it
proactive be used and the second thing
is in terms of I mean Microsoft after
all is the most widely distributed
software on laptops and phones so how
can we I mean developers use this to we
talked about different paradigms of
developers how can we incentivize them
to not only use this for development but
provide some we are may be controlled
feedback so we can get experience
because you are doing the data mining
which is a very valuable thing but it's
very limited also it not very it's
limited to certain questions other
questions you have to do partly
accompanying projects and that's the
part where I say how can we intensive
identifies them to write that feedback I
have few ideas but it is something we
should talk about because it might also
depend a lot on which community
you are dressing but all the new things
that have been developed about a new
models for development involving
developer sir I mean they should be
instrumented in a nice way to to gain
that kind of experience and again I mean
the you said no you said it the data
security issue and so on thank you very
much you're welcome